what we have here is a rather shocking
revelation
the result of a freedom of information
act request
filed by children's health defense
with the cdc what we have here i believe
if i'm seeing it correctly is a document
from the cdc in which they discuss in
early 2021 how they are going to analyze
evidence of adverse events in order to
discover whether or not
the new covid19 vaccines are creating
health problems that are
worthy of some sort of regulatory change
and what they describe
is a regime i believe it is section
2.3 of this document they
outline a mechanism
i would argue and our
good friend matthew crawford has also
argued that it is a very flawed
mechanism for analyzing the data in the
vares system but what they advocate is a
system
the acronym is uh prr and effectively it
involves looking at the ratio of
different
adverse events between vaccines so you
take a new vaccine like the coveted
vaccine
the covet mrna vaccine and you compare
it to a long-standing vaccine and you
see whether the ratio of adverse events
that are reported differs from the prior
vaccine and if it does differ that might
suggest if there's an elevated level of
one particular kind of adverse event it
might suggest
uh that
something is a mess let me just quote
from that document that zach just had up
the relevant portion which you've just
done a very good job of summarizing but
let's just have it
in the cdc's words this is from
the
briefing document posted on the cdc
website in january 2021
updated in february 2022 with minor
changes section
2.3.1 proportional reporting ratio prr
cdc will perform prr data mining on a
weekly basis or as needed prrs compare
the proportion of a specific ae that is
adverse event following a specific
vaccine versus the proportion of the
same ae following receipt of another
vaccine a safety signal is defined as a
prr of at least two chi-squared
statistic of at least four and three or
more cases of the ae following receipt
of the specific vaccine of interest
i sped up because
none of the none of the particulars
matters here it's the first sentence cdc
will perform prr data mining on a weekly
basis or as needed and then the next the
final little paragraph here cdc will
apply appropriate comparative vaccines
e.g adjuvanted vaccines like shrinrix
and or flu add for
19 vaccines and adjust for severity and
age distributions were applicable
and the
the first punch line here which i have
in front of me i don't know maybe you
want to do it or i can just go for it
arrive at it
is that
i'm reading right now from a piece
written by josh gutzkow phd on
the defender blog on children's health
defense who
says you know i was concerned about what
we're going to find with adverse events
but at least the cdc said repeatedly
we're going to be doing this prr
these you know by which we could tell
and you know there are problems itself
with prr as a mechanism yeah for example
if you have two vaccines that have a
high rate of adverse events but the same
ratio of harms it will be not detectable
by this method right so if a particular
adjuvant for example created a given
ratio of arms
and the ratio was therefore the same
between two different vaccines that use
that same adjuvant you wouldn't see it
by this mechanism so the mechanism uh
leaves
many routes by which it would fail to
detect adverse events that matter but
turns out that's not even the problem
here right the problem here is worse
than that
we got a dog we have sorry guys
a dog trapped by equipment yeah so
there are
more obvious and better
ways to assess whether or not you've got
an adverse event associated with a
vaccine the advantage of prr apparently
is that it's simple
there's there's a rubric already in
process it takes basically a push of a
button
it really it really takes almost nothing
to do it and
what i just read from the document that
was first put up by the cdc in january
21 and updated with my changes in
february 22
said quote cdc will perform prr data
manage
cdc will perform prr data mining on a
weekly basis or as needed
and yet when uh
the
children's health defense put in a foia
request a freedom of information act
request to see the results of the prr
again the
the analysis the cdc has said it would
be doing
on the mrna coveted vaccines
the agency wrote quote no prrs were
conducted by cdc furthermore data mining
is outside of the agency's purview
the agency then suggests contacting the
us food and drug administration
which was supposed to perform a
different type of data mining so this is
jaw-dropping
i mean it can't really be a shock to any
of us who've been paying attention to
the absolutely unprecedented adverse
event signal in the vare system and have
been saying all right we keep we are
told that the system which was set up to
detect adverse events um is not reliable
but then if that's true if they're not
paying attention this system are they
paying attention to no system because
it would certainly seem that you would
need to have something monitoring
adverse events in order to know whether
these highly novel vaccines were doing
some
new major kind of damage what we have in
this case is we've got the cdc telling
us exactly what analysis they were going
to perform
when we in the public perform that
analysis we get a very alarming answer
for these vaccines and then when a
freedom of information act request is
directed at the cdc who has told us that
they intended to perform these analyses
the result is they tell us well they
didn't do it which means that apparently
the cdc
was not addressing the question of the
unprecedented adverse event signal from
these vaccines and was simply proceeding
as if it didn't exist this is well going
into public with the talking heads the
people who may have the right
credentials but don't seem to know
anything about how to do science or what
would what it would mean to do so
making claims like on april 27 2021 cdc
director dr rochelle balenski stating
that the cdc does not see any signals
relating to heart inflammation
well on what basis can that claim be
made if they're doing no analysis at all
right i mean you know
did you look in the couch cushions for i
see no heart inflammation right there's
no evidence of heart inflammation in
these couch cushions right so the point
is okay you've got people who are
charged with protecting us from adverse
events you've got a system that was set
up which frankly is set up in such a way
that it is very difficult even for
damaging vaccines to trigger enough uh
of a signal to to get anyone's attention
and in this case you have an outscaled
signal which does show up in this system
does not appear to be anomalous to the
extent it's been looked at um who filed
these reports it's uh overwhelmingly
medical professionals and people
involved in pharmaceutical production
themselves who have filed these reports
it is a match for what we see in the
british yellow card system there's all
kinds of evidence that suggests that
there's a very serious adverse event
problem
and those who are charged with balancing
the risks of a vaccine with the benefits
of that vaccine are apparently blinding
themselves to the very signal that they
would need to analyze in order to decide
whether or not the cost was uh
worth enduring in order to get the
benefit and
you know well go ahead well i just an
image just came to my mind you know we
hear terms that are used somewhat
metaphorically like rudderless the
system seems rudderless perhaps it's
leaderless where there's just a
figurehead there
and i think i think rudderless is wrong
i feel like
to the extent that a boat with a rudder
metaphor is apt here
there is a rudder and there's someone in
charge and they've been told just
cranked it all the way one way no matter
what the rudder's intact and we're just
going to steer the ship that way that
way that way always the same way
and
uh it's not that
it's not random
right the the
the
bad information and bad public health
policy and just bad all the way down
almost with regard to responses to kovid
at the public policy and public health
level have been
not chaotic
they have been not random they have been
not arbitrary they always air in the
same directions and that is what
suggests that
we are not readerless and we are not
leaderless but we are definitely being
driven
we are being driven and we are being
driven in a way that
puts us in peril in other words when
they said safe and effective those were
effectively going to be the conclusions
irrespective of what the evidence
suggested right here we now find out
what safe means which is
it means that they
wrote that into the brochure that was at
best their hope of what would be true
and then they steadfastly
uh
avoided the evidence that would tell
them if they had been incorrect about it
right safe safe as far as we could tell
before we had any data and then we
stopped checking
yeah it's it's it's unclear if even like
that even maybe a generous
interpretation from what we are now
seeing about early results out of the
visor trials right yeah
the other thing and the reason that this
connects to the prior two topics is that
we
are in a polarized environment where
those of us who have attempted to
divine what is actually true about the
costs and benefits of these vaccines
about the hazards of this disease about
the way in which you might risk stratify
people and protect many people who don't
need the vaccines because they're
protected by virtue of being
young and healthy right we have been
demonized
we have been demonized on the basis that
we misunderstood the evidence when in
fact what we are now finding out is that
there was an effort not to see the
evidence that you know of course it
should shock no one that demonizing us
was part of preventing that evidence
from being scrutinized by anyone and the
question is what do we now do about it
if this is what the cdc
does
then
what even is it
what even is it what you know what what
even is it
uh
from which agencies on what basis
were legions really almost all of the
doctors being given their marching
orders which then even
even normally free thinking
often heterodox very qualified to think
scientifically scientists and
researchers themselves said wow this is
a complex landscape i'm going to listen
to my doctor well if the doctors
themselves have been given information
that was incomplete that was dogmatic
that would not change at the face of
evidence
then those scientists who are trusting
their doctors are not acting
scientifically they're acting as if the
authorities would not lie to them and
could not be wrong and so that that is
where we find ourselves now that those
that those
those few of us
who are many more than than than
mainstream media would have you believe
but those few of us who stuck our necks
out and said publicly over and over and
over again actually this doesn't add up
these policies don't seem to be a match
for what we can see and science doesn't
work that way and there's no way that
consensus could have been arrived at so
quickly and have it be a legitimate
scientific consensus those of us who did
that and were you know and were thrown
to the bus and demonetized and told that
we were killing people in all of this
as more and more evidence suggests that
actually
the analysis either hasn't been being
done or when it is being done it
suggests exactly the things that those
of us who've been warning about it were
correct
what now like
fast forward in five years the next one
of these happens
where are the people who are actually
doing the science
and can understand the science well
enough to communicate to people who are
going to be making public policies
because if it's the same people
with the same systems in place we are in
exactly as much trouble as we were
before and even more actually because
now it's really clear
what proportion of the population
is willing to say okay whatever you say
i'll accept i'll accept your thing
i trust you
well
there's that
for the next pandemic there's also the
question i mean
what i don't yet hear
is
a mutiny
right the doctors who were effectively
dragged into gaslighting people who were
injured on the pretense that
adverse events were actually very rare
and therefore most of the people who
walked through the doors of their
doctor's office and said i'm suffering
uh from this vaccine were effectively
turned away told that it was a
coincidence told that it was in their
heads right where are the doctors who
should be
rising up and uh demanding that the cdc
be replaced by an actual cdc
right that
that absence i mean you know who knows
this is a new a new result but i i am
not really expecting to see the doctor
stand up because the doctors have been
dragged into something unholy and you
know the question is which
which thing will now drive them will
they be driven
by the hippocratic oath and the fact
that they have been forced uh or induced
to violate it by a cdc that was only
pretending to be interested in
adverse events
will they be driven by their conscience
now or will they be driven by covering
their asses and not admitting to all of
the patients that they turned away and
shouldn't have
that in fact they screwed up and there
are adverse events there are lots of
them and these people need to be treated
we need to have
you know effectively uh
a rapid bootstrapping of the medicine of
treating the adverse events that come
from these highly novel vaccines
so i guess time will tell
but i'm concerned that
everybody has gotten so used to
parroting the official narrative
that
this is even though it is obviously
jaw-dropping that the cdc
apparently violated its own plan for
monitoring adverse events and didn't
monitor them at all
i'm concerned that that will be treated
as just another
minor anomaly here when in fact it is an
indication of exactly what's gone wrong
[Music]